j'aurais d'abord vous dire tout le
plaisir que la france a eu d'organiser
cette réunion informelle ici à
montpellier remercié les autorités
locales monsieur le maire de
l'accompagnement que vous avez bien
voulu mener pour la bonne tenue de cette
réunion informelle merci aussi monsieur
le préfet de services de la préfecture
qui nous ont accompagnés c'était
important
malgré tout de tenir ce sommet ces deux
rencontres informelles quand on dit
rencontres informelles ça veut dire
qu'il ya pas de décision prise à la fin
de la réunion et nous tenions à ce que
cette réunion soit organisée à
montpellier parce que il y à issy
d'abord une un sommet afrique-france
mémorable il recourt à l'automne dernier
et puis qu'il ya aussi ici sur les
sujets qui concernent le développement
une tradition d'innovation de recherche
d'intervention avec le cirad d'une part
cjr votre part plus les enjeux
d'agro écologie qui sont développés dans
l'ensemble de ce coût pour eux je
pourrais appeler une espèce de kloster
rue agroécologiques de de montpellier
qui fait que ça donne de la force de la
résonance aux sujets que nous avons
abordé aujourd'hui et singulièrement je
lui dis monsieur le maire au troisième
sujet que nous avons abordé avec le
président issoufou sur l'affirmation du
grand projet de la grande muraille verte
qui est un projet agro écologiques qui
regroupe onze pays du sahel qui mobilise
aujourd'hui 16 milliards d'euros et qui
a pour objectif de non seulement de
créer dry verte son nom est suffisamment
évocateur mais de faire en sorte que de
de la guinée-bissau jusqu'à djibouti
puisse y avoir cette mise en valeur
d'une nouvelle histoire du sel qui
permettrait de fixer les populations qui
permettra aussi d'assurer une nouvelle
agriculture et qui permettrait aussi
d'assurer la stabilité et que le
président issoufou reviennent pour
parler de cela a été pour nous tous pour
les vingt-sept très mobilisateur très
passionnant dans les perspectives et le
fait que ce que pour ma part je ne
savais pas
mais je pense que personne ne les avait
vraiment que le président issoufou et
fait ses études à montpellier qui
reviennent 46 ans après ici dans une
autre histoire d'une autre aventure
c'était quand même assez émouvant
sur avant de revenir à l'ukraine sur
les enjeux géopolitiques je pense que ce
que je retire je crois que c'est assez
partagé par josep borrell que je sais
que nous pensons vraiment la même chose
sur ce sujet c'est que sur les enjeux
géopolitiques du développement c'est que
l'europe doit tenir sa place
nous nous sommes les premiers bailleurs
au niveau mondial des dettes publiques
au développement les européens tous
réunis team europe et nous ne disons pas
ce bien plus important que la chine
compte comme les états unis dans l'aide
au développement partout dans le monde
et singulièrement en afrique mais pas
uniquement et nous le disons pas parce
qu'une espèce de l'absence de lisibilité
de ce que nous sommes je crois que ce
matin nous avons vraiment cette option
d'affirmer que l'europe et ce partenaire
là et qu'elle doit s'articuler aux
réalités d'une compétition
internationale parce que le
développement c'est aussi une
compétition d' influence on le voit
d'ailleurs dans certains votes aux
nations unies et nous devons nous mêmes
évitez d'instrumentaliser le
développement à des fins politiciennes
les fins de suggestions mais développe
et faire en sorte que le développement
soit un outil de partenariat qui
respecte la souveraineté des pays avec
lesquels nous sommes en co développement
puisqu'il ya des sujets du développement
qui sont obligatoirement partenariat que
ce soit la lutte pour le réchauffement
climatique ou les enjeux de biens
d'exercice et de l'eau rien de parler
donc je ressort de cette réunion avec la
conviction c'est être prise de
conscience de l'affirmation de l'europe
comme
de développement et comme ayant la
capacité d'établir des partenariats qui
évite la suggestion ou la dépendance
alors que certains autres en font leur
priorité
et puis nous avons évidemment parlé
longuement
le drame qui se joue cette tragédie
dans
nous sommes loin d'être sortis
avec la mobilisation financière dont tu
as parlé josep borrell à la fois sur
l'aide humanitaire
les 500 millions d'euros qui sont et qui
ont été annoncés la france y contribuera
elle aussi puisque nous avons à la
demande du président de la république
que décidé de mobiliser 100 millions
d'euros d'aidé humanitaire pour les
réfugiés
ou les déplacés réfugiés et déplacés
dans sur l'espace ukrainien et puis nous
avons aussi décidé de l'accompagner les
financements budgétaire
sur la part d un milliard deux que tu as
évoqué tout à l'heure la france
mobilisera 300 millions d'euros mais ça
c'est pour l'immédiateté nous sommes
partis dans un drame de longue durée sur
lequel nous sommes extrêmement mobilisés
parce qu'on voit bien que ce qui est
recherché c'est finalement la négation
de l'ukraine le déni d'ukraine et donc
le fait que l'ukraine soit plis et les
conditions de
négociations proposée par le président
poutine n'ont pas changé depuis 11 jours
c'est à dire c'était conditions de
négociation soumission
et cela nous paraît inacceptable on ait
eu l'occasion au cours de cette
rencontre de réaffirmer notre totale
solidarité avec leucan ce qui me frappe
le plus je crois que j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de le dire à plusieurs
reprises dans d'autres lieux
c'est d'abord que l'union européenne a
été uni alors que le président poutine
comptait sur nos divisions
elle a été unie elle a été rapide dans
ses décisions elle a été forte dans ses
décisions audacieuses même l'europe
telle qu'elle est aujourd'hui n'est plus
la même que celle qui existait il ya dix
jours encore temps le chemin qualitatif
fait de soutenir le cren les y compris
dans le domaine des équipements
militaires le fait qu'ils aient de des
sanctions énormes qui ont été décidées
et qui sont mises en oeuvre que cela se
passe dans une très grande rapidité le
seul fait même qu' on puisse se mettre
d'accord sur la protection temporaire
des réfugiés en quelques heures sur des
sujets où il faut des compromis
généralement très long et très compliqué
où chacun doit faire des efforts et l'a
rapidement ça se met en oeuvre tout ça
aboutit au fait que la violence de la
tacc de l'ukraine par la russie a
entraîné une stimulation très forte de
la part de l'union européenne qui du
coup fait qu' elle n'est plus la même
aujourd'hui qu'il y ait encore des jours
et je suis convaincu que cela se
confortera et se confirmera lors du
sommet qui va se tenir en france jeudi
et vendredi à l'initiative du président
macron voilà l'essentiel de ce que je
voulais dire